good morning believe nation its Evan my
one word is believe I believe in you and
I want to see that awesome thing that
you have inside you explode out into the
universe to have a major impact so to
help you on your journey today's message
is don't quit over to you Robert
Kiyosaki is there a time to bail out on
a project though I mean when I don't
that's not in my vocabulary yeah look I
have a I have an unfair advantage you
know I went to war a war I'm alive
because other guys died for me when you
see stuff like that you know how can I
quit most guys I just wimps [ __ ]
cowards they don't have it so they
should should get a job most people quit
too soon in their ideas and it's why you
keep hearing so many people on this
channel and I've said it - you can't
quit never quit don't quit but there are
some times when you need to quit and let
me just explain a little bit more I
think the reason why so many people
share that message up don't quit is
because too often entrepreneurs will
start and stop and start and stop and
never actually see any of their ideas
through and so if you have this passion
for what you're doing and you give up on
it too soon as soon as you hit some kind
of financial break or some other
obstacles in your way you get some kind
of rejection
most people will quit so it's too hard
I'm not going to do that anymore I'm
gonna stop I'm gonna give up I'm gonna
go find something else and they quit
that's the case you should not quit
right that's why so many people have
that message for you but sometimes
people quit too late as well sometimes
I've seen it happen to a lot of
entrepreneurs you've lost the passion
for it and you know you've had some
success with this business or you just
don't want to you just don't want to
feel like a failure
and so you don't want to quit but you
hang on too long - this thing that you
shouldn't be doing maybe that
relationship you're in you should quit
on like maybe that's not a healthy
relationship for you
maybe that business that you're in is
not right for you don't hang on to it
just because you don't want to feel like
a failure failure is normal it was part
of the process so how do you know when
you should
quit and when you shouldn't quit the
answer comes down to when you're
passionate hard-ons if you are
passionate about your business if your
heart is still in it if you want to
build this amazing thing up and you have
this dream then you can't quit on it
that's when you have to keep going if
you have the passion you have to keep
going even if it doesn't make sense even
if there's no clear path you will find
the path eventually if you keep going
for me when I started doing this helping
entrepreneurs I had three people show up
to a free event
there's only it was free and only three
people showed up like logically how are
you gonna make money off of this how
will this ever become a business it
doesn't make any sense but didn't matter
for made sense because I loved it and I
had to find a way to keep going and
doing it even if I never made a way to
make money out of it and it's one of the
most common messages that come up not
just on this channel but when you study
successful people's you need to follow
your passion you got to do the thing
that you're so insanely passionate about
how many times have you heard that
message on this channel and from the
people we've profiled it keeps coming up
over and over and over again and there's
a reason because one of the single most
important ingredients of success so as
long as you still have that passion for
your business and you have to keep going
you have to keep following through you
can't quit because you will get it at
some point you'll regret quitting
because you'll be looking back on your
life in five years 10 years 50 years and
saying I could have done more you know I
could have I could have what if I just
gave it another 3 months what if I just
give it another 6 months what if I just
tried a little bit harder you'll always
have that piece eating at you not you
not you for the rest of your life it can
turn you bitter and angry and then
complaining for the rest of your life
because you could have done more and so
if you still have that passion you have
to find a way to keep going even if it
means taking a job doing something else
supporting yourself in other ways you
have to find a way to keep going every
day consistently don't quit but if
you've lost the passion for it just
feels like a grind it just feels like
work it just feels boring it feels
uncomplicated it feels just like you've
got this huge boulder on your head every
time you have to go and think about work
then you should quit and either sell the
business if it's built up to the point
where you can sell it to somebody
or just stop and go do something else
because you will create insane value
when you're doing work that you love
when you enjoy right not every minute
not every minutes amazing but net like
you're doing something that is worthy if
you feel like you're doing work that is
worthy you will pour your heart into it
and make something amazing you do that
consistently you're gonna become the
best in the world at it and you will get
paid eventually everybody's Road looks
like that you know it's not like it's an
instant success to most people it's
years of struggle and then they hit it
if I continue to hone their craft but if
you're walking in the work with this
Boulder on your head and you can't stand
being there and you feel like the work
you're doing socks it has no meaning
you're just wasting your time you're
counting down until the clock hits
whatever time when you're gonna go home
you're wasting your time and you'll
never create anything amazing for those
people there don't let that fear of
being labeled a quitter
or labeled a failure keep you in
something in a relationship in a
business in an opportunity that isn't
right for you if you don't have the
passion then you should quit you still
have the passion you can't quit you've
got to find a way to keep going so the
question today today is I'm curious for
those of you who have a deep passion for
your business what is the thing that is
keeping you in this company maybe you've
had a lot of success maybe you haven't
hit your stride yet but what is the
thing that is forcing you to stay in
this company and not quit what does that
mean to you hopefully by writing it down
it ignites a fire within yourself and
can also inspire the other people
watching share your thoughts down in the
comments below I also want to give a
quick Charta to Miko Sal kolache from
Sal collage calm Nico thank you so much
for picking up a copy of my book your
one word I really really appreciate it
and I hope you're enjoying the read
thank you guys again for watching I hope
you have an amazing day I believe in you
I hope we continue to believe in
yourself
and whatever you're one where it is much
love and I'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot of an espresso
espresso give me go
so unfortunate a lot of people stand in
front of the stove of life and they say
now stove you give me some heat then
I'll put some wood in you that ain't the
way it works you got to put something in
before you can get anything out so many
times you know the employee goes to the
employer and say give me a raise then
I'll start coming to work on time all
right so many times they will come to
him and say make me the boss now I know
I haven't been here very long don't
really deserve to be the law but I just
function better when I am in charge of
things you reward me now and then I
promise you I'll learn what this
business is all about later on reward me
now and I'll produce later doesn't work
that way kids you just see a youngster
in school saying teach you if I take a
failing grade home my parents gonna skin
me alive paste me on this quarter and
next time I'll study more than anybody
else reward me now I'll produce later it
doesn't work that way can't you just see
an old farmer standing out in the fields
in October and said Lord I know I didn't
plant a thing this year but if you give
me a big crop this year I'll plant more
than anybody next year it ain't that way
folks you gotta put something in before
you can expect to get anything out well
you just a pumping away you know that's
hard it's August I mean the question is
just how much pumping are you gonna do
Parker I drink the water and finally Oh
Bernard said you know Jimmy I don't
believe you're sending water down there
Jimmy said yeah it is Bernard you know
in South Alabama the worlds are deepened
oh we're glad they're deep because the
deeper the well the cool of the cleaner
the sweeter the pure the better tasting
the water and isn't that true of life
into that if you can become an MD by six
weeks of summer school that the rewards
would be almost minimal or nothing and
how many paces would you have ended sir
that if you become a sales expert in
three days of a training school or that
the rate of pay would go down rather
radically isn't it true that anything
worth doing is worth doing poorly until
you can learn to do it well we'll never
know how many kids have missed a college
scholarship because they didn't study an
average of ten more minutes a day we
will never know how we come so close to
promotion but we're good discouraged and
quit too soon we'll never know how much
more success we would have Hey
had we just had a little more pumping in
there and pump and pump and pump and
pump well finally Oh Bernard just got
disgusted through booze and you said
Jimmy there's just no water down there
Jimmy said don't stop my life don't stop
if you stop day what is going to go all
the way back down and then you're gonna
have to start all over the reality is
folks and I'm totally convinced of this
this is the story of America this is
your story this is the story of success
this is the story of life I believe with
all of my heart that if you would pump
long enough and hard enough and
enthusiastically enough that eventually
the reward is going to follow the effort
and then once that water starts to flow
all you got to do is just people to be
easy steady pressure on it and you're
going to get more water than you can
possibly so many times people get
involved in something and they'll say
well I'll give it a try and if it works
out that'll be good and if it if it
doesn't work out I mean hang on kill the
track you know what I mean by the way
well I gotta tell you something folks
you're gonna pump forever like that
before anything happens when you get
into something grab that sucker and did
with it and then once the water starts
to flow then ladies and gentlemen
that's what strategies for success is
all about now here's an important point
nothing works the first time when you
try something new it probably won't work
when you try something new several times
it probably won't work and the turning
point in my life came when I would hear
good ideas and I was so eager to be
successful in selling I would run out
and try the ideas and they wouldn't work
I try a way of getting an appointment or
answering an objection or closing a sale
it wouldn't work and my natural response
ah and I think yes to be disappointed
and then I realized nothing works at
least the first few times so I decided I
would try a new idea five or ten times
before I pass judgment on I would not
just try it once and quit like most
people do and that changed my whole life
it was a turning point in my life
because I realized from then on if
you've got a good idea and you've got a
good goal and you want to double your
income and improve the quality of your
life and you have to try new things in
order to get new results it's not going
to work the first time say say well that
didn't work try something else and try
something else and try something else
now if you try
only two things can happen what are they
succeed or fail if you succeed you do
more of it if you fail you learn from it
get smarter and try it again so you
cannot lose by taking action you could
only lose by not taking action but why
did you still believe in the company I
mean I have to think that that at any
point in Silicon Valley history there's
a lot of people that at that point
they're just like this isn't going to
work
markets changed this isn't a viable
concept anymore well you know I I don't
know how much belief I had but I knew
that I had kind of gotten everybody into
the boat with me so it wasn't so much
that I didn't want to quit I wanted to
quit every day I was in that job I felt
like throwing up when I woke up in the
morning do you know what it's like
having a baby now yeah exactly like I
felt like I was pregnant but you know
I'd hired every employee and they all
trust me I'd raised all the money I
talked every investor into putting their
money and I had given stock to you know
like my friends and relatives and they
were all excited about the prospects for
the company when it went public like a
lot of my friends from high school like
bought the stock because I was running
the company and so I just I felt like I
could die but I couldn't quit and you
know one of the horrible things about
being founder CEO is it's the one job
you really can't quit or if you do quit
you're Punk
so yeah you know I didn't want to be a
punk so I I just kept you know I just
kept pedaling but it was rough I mean
like that was a running floud cloud yeah
right and it didn't stop there right
like that was loud loud loud cloud you
know by the time loud cloud was two and
a half years old I had like sold like
the loud cloud part of the business and
I had to change it into another business
no like that the next thing that
happened was right loud cloud was going
to go bankrupt so I raised 160 million
dollars in the IPO but like I burned you
know like we burnt through that and we
couldn't stop the burn because the
customers
going out of business and so like we
were headed towards bankruptcy so then I
had to you know I sold the services part
of the business and all the cash burn
TDs and and then I had to lay off you
know probably you know another third of
the employees and then I kept the
remaining 80 employees and we became a
software company a publicly traded
software company with no customers in a
revenue which was an another trip ops
where that's when we became ops where
yeah so like that was hard but it was
good you know if that kind of stuff it
makes you strong you know eventually you
know we five years later we sold to heel
at Packard for you know 1.6 billion
dollars and not a bad exit which was
like still I'm still shocked by that
whole thing I'm still wake up in the
middle of the night going are we're
gonna run out of money if you had to
think of one word that's most important
to you or that sums you up or so it
would be like a little beacon pay
believe nation if you want to know what
the most important one word is for Tony
Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah Winfrey
will.i.am and Howard Schultz I have a
very special secret video for you check
the description for details